president nauseated
dear mayor and the entire community
involved in realizing this exciting
program
what a special city you have
kaunas our european capital of culture
for 2022.
once a medieval city transformed into a
vanguard of modernism
at that time
the capital of a newly independent
nation
counters accomplished a new beginning
in these interwar years
modernism in art and architecture
stood for more than an artistic style
it represented a new vision for
lithuania's future and its people
built on pragmatism progress
and independence
now one hundred years later we are again
at a crossroad
asked to re-imagine our future while
protecting nature
but we can only succeed if we use all
our talents from art and culture to
technology and innovation
and this is why we launched the new
european bauhaus
a movement to combine
sustainability and style to support the
european green deal
our european capitals of culture can
help lead this change
especially with the support of young
people and this is why i decided to make
2022
the european year of youth
to promote youth engagement at all
levels
like with emerging counters
your city's youth program
so i call on all young europeans and
those young at heart
to use their creative energy to build a
greener european future
it was here in kaunas 100 years ago
that a young nation reimagined
its identity through modernism
again today
europe is reimagining its future
through sustainability
and once again
art mirrors this great transformation
in a free and united europe
i wish you a wonderful year of european
capital of culture you deserve it
and i hope to visit soon